.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, IMTIAZ TYAB
REPORTING FROM SOUTHERN ISRAEL.
>>> PRESIDENT BIDEN PLANS TO
SIGN A BILL TODAY AIMED AT
FIGHTING A SURGE IN
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST ASIAN
AMERICANS AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS.
THE COVID-19 HATE CRIMES ACT
PASSED THE HOUSE YESTERDAY.
THE VOTE THERE WAS 364-62.
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI
CALLED IT A MOMENTOUS DAY.
WEIJIA JIANG IS AT THE WHITE
HOUSE WITH MORE.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
WHAT EXACTLY DOES THIS BILL DO?
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING TO
YOU, GAYLE.
GOOD MORNING, EVERYONE.
WELL, THIS WILL PROVID MORE
RESOURCES TO HELP CURB THE
NUMBER OF ANTI-ASIAN HATE
INCIDENT THAT'S HAVE JUST SOARED
DURING THE PANDEMIC STARTING
WITH A NEW POSITION AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO HELP
EXPEDITE THE HANDLING OF
ALLEGATIONS OF HATE CRIMES.
IT WILL ALSO DIRECT THE DOJ AND
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
SECRETARY TO WORK WITH VARIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS TO GIVE GUIDANCE
THAT WILL HELP VICTIMS REPORT
INCIDENTS AND RAISE PUBLIC
AWARENESS.
THE LAW WOULD PROVIDE GRANTS TO
TRAIN LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
IDENTIFY HATE CRIMES AND FOR
STATES TO HELP SET UP REPORTING
HOTLINES.
SOME ADVOCATES ARE CONCERNED
THAT THE BILL DOES NOT GO FAR
ENOUGH TO ADDRESS THE UNDERLYING
CAUSES OF THE ATTACKS OR TO
ANYTHING TO CLARIFY WHAT
CONSTITUTES A HATE CRIME.
THEY ARE ALSO FRUSTRATED THAT IT
DOES NOT ALLOCATE ANY NEW
FUNDING FOR THE AAIP COMMUNITY.
MORE THAN 100 ASIAN AND LGBTQ
ORGANIZATIONS ACTUALLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL SAYING IT DOES NOT DO
ENOUGH TO HELP OTHER
MARGINALIZED GROUPS.
BUT THERE IS AGREEMENT THAT THIS
IS A CRITICAL FIRST STEP WITH
MORE THAN 6,600 ANTI-ASIAN HATE
INCIDENTS